good morning everybody and welcome to
this meeting of mid-suffolk District
Council cabinet
I'm councilor Susie Morley and I will be
chairing this meeting today
I'm just going to first remind you of
some domestic Arrangements
please ensure that microphones are
turned off when not in use
please do not interrupt other speakers
or hold separate conversations whilst
others are speaking
if you are attending the meeting to
speak and persistently interrupt the
meeting you may be asked to leave
please ensure your mobile phones are on
silent or Switched Off
and we will be using e-voting for this
meeting on the modern.gov app so please
make sure you're logged in and ready to
use the app
I'd just like to remind everyone present
that this means
mihos live to the internet and we'll be
capable of repeated viewing
the whole of the meeting will be filmed
except where there are confidential or
exempt items
if you make a representation to the
meeting you will be deemed by the
council to have consented to being
filmed
by entering this meeting as a speaker
you are also consenting to being
recorded by the council and to the
possible use of those images and sound
recordings for webcasting purposes
council members of the public and the
Press May record film photograph or
broadcast this meeting when the public
and the Press are not lawfully excluded
I'm just going to move now to the agenda
item one is apologies for absence
thank you chair we have received
apologies from councilor Gould
thank you very much
item two is to receive Declarations of
pecuniary other registerable or
non-registerable interests by members
are there any to declare
item three is MCA slash 22
28 to confirm the minutes of the meeting
held on the 3rd of October 2022
are there any points regarding the
accuracy of the minutes
a clever proposal please councilor
headingham and a second up please cancel
soon
thank you
if you could conduct the vote please
thank you chair the vote is now in
progress I have yes counselor
four thank you
thank you chair that's unanimous
thank you very much item four is to
receive notification of petitions in
accordance with the council's petition
scheme
thank you chair we have received over
500 entries of which 143 was valid
um regarding report MCA
22-27 elmswell Exemplar housing scheme
in ellsworld
thank you councilor Richardson
thanks very much chair I wanted to make
a brief uh comment following the receipt
of that petition as members will be
aware uh following the well-attended
engagement event in elmsworld in
November about the potential to deliver
and Exemplar housing scheme in the
village we are reviewing the feedback
received and to have further meetings
arranged with key stakeholders in the
coming weeks
we want to work with the local community
to ensure they have the facilities they
need however the ultimate decision over
Primary School provision for Realms well
rests with Suffolk County Council as a
local education Authority and they have
been clear that they have no plans for a
further School in the village
we are however Keen to find the best
solution for the local community and we
are busy working our way through the
feedback received while continuing
conversations so that our next steps can
be considered this matter will also be
going to overview in scrutiny in January
and welcome the opportunity to share
further information including feedback
from the recent engagement event which
we estimate around 200 people attended
and I'd like I'd like to thank everyone
for their engagement to date
teacher
thank you councilor Richardson
um item five is questions by councils
none received gem
and item six matters referred by the
overview and scrutiny or the joint audit
and standards committees there are no
matters referred to
item seven is the
reasons list are there any comments on
those items
so moving on now to item eight
this is the
um general fund Financial monitoring
report for
2022-23 Quarter Two
MCA slash 22-29
I'm going to invite the cabinet member
for finance to introduce the report
yeah thank you madam chairman for the
first of my two reports today I'd like
to introduce MCA 2229 which is a general
fund Financial monitoring for Quarter
Two to twenty three so it's based on six
months of actual financial data from
April to September this year which is
then used to forecast the outcome for
the full year 22-23
and the report sets out to explain any
significant variances against budget
in my introduction to the q1 outturn
report I indicated how inflationary cost
pressures have built up a real head of
steam since the start of this calendar
year
and at that point you were forecasting
additional cost increases of 1.184
million in 2223
and we've now revised that upwards
albeit only by very marginally to 1.238
million and increased 54 000.
now to offset that increase that we have
399 000 of carry forward reserves carry
forward forwards and that leaves the net
expenditure over spend of 839 000.
when allowance is taken for the 500 000
inflationary pressure reserved which we
set up at the end of last year that
leaves just 339 000 to be offset against
the growth and efficiency fund
we had budgeted a 3.351 million surplus
to go into the Grove efficiency fund
this year
so with the overspend now forecasted
that still leaves the surface position
of Revenue compared to expenditure of
just over 3 million
so in essence this quarter two outturn
report confirms we are still very much
in a similar position to that which we
anticipated in the quarter one out turn
report
and with their front two space still
having reserves just under 20 million by
the year end
in addition to the revenue budget this
report looks at our Capital program
it's three pages an appendix beak of the
full details
we've spent 6.184 million in the first
six months of the year the book that
being on Gateway 14.
we expect our total Capital spend for
the year to be Hefty
29.829 Million by year end with
significant capital expenditure to come
in the second half of the year
that includes over 2 million on
replacement Refuge Freighters a large
investment intermittent growth and a
substantial further investment into the
gateway 14 project
I'd now like to move the recommendations
in paragraph three which clearly State
the information is for now just for
noting
so I'd request this fellow account
member to Second these recommendations
and then I along with Rebecca from the
finance team here to answer any
questions Academy members or other
counselors may have thank you madam
chair
thank you counselor Mike
Taylor Richardson
thank you chair happy to Second this
report thanks thank you very much
um do we have any questions from cabinet
do we have any questions from any other
members
councilor Eber
um thank you very much chair and thank
you councilor Whitehead for for that um
introduction
um I've got a couple of questions if I
may firstly
um within the corporate resources area
there's
um the 500 000 pounds of vacancy
management
um could you explain how that's offset
because I understand that goes across
all services
um
secondly with regards to the capital
there are some very big carry forwards
in the um
at also from play equipment car Parks
the um
disabled facilities grants
and and the Strategic investment fund
and in the report at 5.8 it says some
items are unlikely to be fully spent and
I wonder if you could just give us a bit
more detail on those thank you very much
thank you chair
thank you Catherine uh let me just get
my papers into order here
um
500 pounds of um 500 000 pounds of
vacancy management
um my understanding is that that's been
budgeted against corporate resources but
of course the effect is across all areas
but if Rebecca can you want to just add
a bit more to that put a bit of flesh on
the bones please yes certainly that's
that is correct so we we budget for the
the assumed five percent transitional
vacancies and it will see through the
year it within corporate resources
um so on the corporate resources line
that shows as an over an overspend
effectively when we we look at that in
isolation the the underspends that are
being seen due to actual transitional
vacancies will be throughout throughout
the services so we'll see
um under spends in in each of the
services relating to to salaries
um and then their corporate resources
line will show an overspend against that
that
Channel
um thank you thank you for that
um answer so just
so in terms of actually understanding
where the vacancy ones are one has to
look at individual surface area service
areas and just assume that that 500k
split
across all of the
you know Services you're not gonna one
doesn't have to add them all up across
the
um
across the different service areas as it
were does that make sense yeah
Rebecca's nodding in so much
yes that's that's right so they are they
are there within the universe Services
it's really hard to split them out
separately because of the wave Reserve
funding and everything else feeds into
that but yes they are they are there
okay well no sorry in terms of question
about the capital
um as you say there's quite a quite a
large amount of uh carry forwarded
um anticipated total of of 6 million and
you know the details are there
um
well I think the comments that try to
explain where the what you know the
status of each project and where they
carry forward is but obviously on these
long-term capital they will inevitably
be carried forward
so if you're just if you want to just
specific ones you were asking about
please um well the the you know I picked
a few play equipment Carl Parks um
disabled
we always seem to have a problem with
the disabled um facilities Grant and
carry forward it's just
you know is there obviously last year
was kind of covered but this year you
know is there a is there another
rationale or another reasoning for the
fact that these are being
um so much as being carried forward
um and
uh you know just a bit more sort of
detail on that really thank you
any
more detail to drill down we'll have to
supply outside the meeting but um I
think the as you say covid did delay
things and in terms of catching upon
these large programs it'll take take it
will take more than a year and as you
say the discretory facilities grants we
obviously families you were spending
those but as the comment says there's
now a new social media campaign to try
and encourage more applications
foreign
yes
um councilman has got most of the issues
I was interested in but um
the further question on that capital
resources figure rather surprise the
budget was 1.7 the forecast is 2.5
million spend
but the 500k that you're talking about
surely we knew about a budget time so we
would have been incorporated then so a
little surprise to see a an explanation
that gives us
um uh some Bank charges uh 70k and 30k
of um
insurance contract that's a hundred out
of a 790k overspend
even if I take 100 of 790 I don't think
I end up with 500 so I still really
don't understand that issues I'm a
little more wood
be good the the other question I had
really was um
looking looking at the uh the carry
forwards basically the Mr reserves
a number of these we seem to be
ending as well what would hope for good
things and there's some like uh planning
legal which are clearly things that will
sit there in case something happens for
some time I was surprised climate change
and biodiversity we have 927 Grand there
we've only spent 72 in the whole year
and this is something which most of us
see there's pretty vital at the moment
so I wondered if there was
with those two things in the corporate
resources and just a word about climate
change and biodiversity why are we not
um moving ahead with that
thank you
I think in terms of the question on
corporate resources which I understood
the question is the bit more detail
about the seven ninety thousand and
trying to build that up from the the the
explanations given I think we need to
perhaps just take that away and look at
that you know in terms of for a more
detailed answer and that's Rebecca just
feels she can answer it but before that
in fact just sort of say in terms of the
earmark reserves this is one of the big
areas we'll be looking at in terms of
the new 2324 budget to sort of justify
what those are and
well just the carrying value of them
thank you certainly an explanation of
the 1.7 versus 2.5 million in detail a
bit later would be quite welcome
yes we can provide that details for 500
000 of that is the vacancy and there are
lots of other smaller smaller bits
building up the difference between that
and the key variances but we will
provide that that detail upon exactly
exactly thank you any more questions
so I'll Now open up the item for debate
does anybody wish to debate this item
okay so the recommendations are that
subject 25 further budget variations
that arise during the rest of the
financial year the net expenditure
overspend position of 839
000 pounds and forecast Reserve
movements referred to in section 5.5 and
appendix a of the report be noted
and also that the revised
2021-22 Capital program referred to in
appendix B and section 5.9 be noted
so I'm now going to ask the governance
officer to conduct the vote
thank you chair the vote has now
progressed
uh that is eight votes four chair that's
unanimous
thank you very much item nine is MCA
slash 22 30 and this is the housing
revenue account Financial monitoring for
2022-23 and I'm going to invite the
cabinet member for finance to introduce
this report
thank you again Madam chairman so now
pleased to introduce report MCA 2230 the
housing revenue account Financial
monitoring for Quarter Two And as for
the general fund we've now got six
months of actual financial data with
three extrapolate the current Year's
Outlook
and at this point the information is for
noting only in contrast to the budget
set for 20 to 23 which showed a surplus
of 95 000 we now are forecasting a
deficit of 675 000. this is therefore a
772 000 adverse movement to budget and
it's a deterioration of 281 000 compared
to our forecasted outturn at the q1
period
under the housing management expense
area we're now forecasting an able to
spend 132 000 due to increase in staff
costs and National pay award and from
the new post creative support the
service transformation
we have a 48 000 pound contract increase
from public Realms grounds maintenance
contract
another other items were a similar
magnitude to the q1 forecast
I think this Q2 reporting was split out
from Building Services as a separate
line item the cost of subcontractors to
support the trades team in completing
the backlog work arising from during the
covid restrictions
here we had a budget of 588 000 which
we're now forecasting to cost 760 000.
subcontractor cost to support the trades
team and completing properties along
with Associated material costs or also
have a significant cost overrun
that's offset in part by an increasing
recharges
if the forecasted deficit proves to be
accurate and clearly this is still a big
if at the moment given the deterioration
from the Q and extrapolation then the
HRA reserves balances at the end of the
year will be 0.3 million
those reserves will be adequate to find
out several years of HRA deficit at its
present run rate but clearly we should
not underestimate the challenges facing
our HRA
and the urgent need for a service
transformation to bring it back to a
long-term sustainable position
the capital position is set out in
appendix a in the first six months we've
spent 6.8 million across several new
building acquisition sites
1.282 million on planned maintenance
along with 150 000 and adaptations to
the stock and 33 000 on that ICT
projects
by the year end we anticipate a total
Capital spend of 24.481 million and a
carry forward into the next year of
18.642 million
I'd now like to move the recommendations
in paragraph three which are merely to
note the revenue budget net adverse
variance and to know the progress on the
capital program
and I'd like to invite the capital
Cabinet member for housing to Second
these recommendations then we'll be
happy to take questions from cabinet
members and other counselors thank you
thank you do we have any questions from
cabinet
any questions from any other members
Council field
looking at the
the table for the uh
Paris 6.5 the tele table talks about
total income and total expenditure
obviously
I note that the housing management and
Building Services if you take those two
things and combine them
they come to about 50 of the rental
income
and obviously that rental income has to
pay back capital and earn interest on on
loans so our question really is
is that sort of ratio of spend
typical of other housing authorities or
do we spend more or do we spend less
particularly interesting because as we
all see we're talking about a 12
increase in one and a nine percent
hiking the other so
are we looking at a big increase on a
low spend or a big increase on a spend
which is already in line with um
the average
the second thing not really uh wondering
looking at housing management overspend
obviously staff costs are an
understandable issue and that's adequate
adequate but I notice there's 50k in
missing Care Plus invoices
there's 27k historically budgeted
incorrectly
there's
um
16k of mobile software missing from the
budget
there's
6K of Western cold water rates not
included in the budget
I wonder this does look you know quite a
inaccurate budget process and wonder
whether Cabinet member is doing anything
to improve the um
accuracy
in the future
actually leave it there for a minute do
have a couple of others
Council Whitehead no sorry yes thank you
Council feel
um in terms of benchmarking our costs
against
um other councils I don't have any
information to hand I'm not you sure if
that has been done but I guess it would
be quite useful uh
exercise to get carry out
um but it is very much a
staff intensive
process managing our Council housing
stock
in terms of these inaccuracies I think
the total yeah
the four items in there which come to
just under 100
000 which in the scheme of nearly seven
million isn't a large figure but it's
still
um
oh yeah it's not something to be happy
with really
um so we intent in terms of uh budgeting
each year we do try and you know look
learn from past mistakes and try and
reduce the level of those
in anything you want to add Rebecca
it's just to to confirm that we have
looked in quite a bit more detail this
year at that budget and um with a new
business partner as well with fresh eyes
on it a lot of these things have come
out of the woodwork during the last year
as a as a result of that so yeah we will
continue to with that process to ensure
that we're we're getting that as
accurately as we can
and come back I mean thank you that uh I
mean it obviously implies to me staff
change isn't a lack of experience and
people are forgetting quite large items
which are which is
doesn't look good for our to our
residents
the next question really on building
service where you have an adverse of 338
you talk about
substantial costs of materials or some
items going up by 130 and that might be
three tap washes that went up an awful
lot so I was wondering
um how much is the materials as that
part of that 638k overspend
um and the um 172 Kion repairs and
maintenance a little bit lower down
the overspend is says due to the use of
subcontractors the same sort of wording
is in the
638k in the in
few bullet points above I wondered
whether I need to add those two things
together to get a total overspend on
subcontractors or are they actually um
is the second item part of the first one
now the the two items do need to be
taken added together the the first item
relates to completing work on
void properties and giving them back to
a satisfactory situation the second one
talks about the completing a backlog of
jobs built up at this General Repair and
maintenance jobs built up during the
covid restrictions so you need to add
the two together
thank you and the amount of materials
included in the 6-3 acre
well I don't have that to handle that
from Becca has or whether we can come
back later
it's likewise I don't have that detail
to hand but I can take that away and and
find that out for you
cancer even
thank you very much chair
um I too was going to ask about the um
the sort of missing costs and things
because it just struck me that's all
budgeting and cost control wasn't as
rigorous as it as it should be but
you've answered that one now but I do
think we need to keep an eye on that one
um my other question is have the lack of
capital spend
um so we've spent I think 8.2 million
against 43.1 million but I just wondered
how that impacts on the overall budget
in terms of Interest payable and so on
what kind of effect
um does that have thank you
well any delay to the capital program
against the budget would have a
reduction in interest payable because
the delay is there so
um we should generally be seen as
positive but of course we're bearing in
mind that interest payable rates of
significantly higher than we budgeted
last year that would have the opposite
effect as well
yeah because presumably the the interest
payable is you know we've got
um
fairly fixed rates on lots of our
um what we're paying but I just wondered
if that was able to be be Quantified and
if it is where can I I kind of find it
obviously we want to spend the budget
you know you want to spend the capital
but it's
it would just be good to know what that
actual impact is and I appreciate if you
haven't got the figures to hand then I
just
might not be aware of those thank you
well if you look at table on 6.5 you'll
see at the moment the we aren't showing
any variances against either
depreciation interest payable or Revenue
contribution to Capital that's an area
which historically ascended to catch up
with us at the year end or towards the
end of the year and I know it's an area
that Melissa and Rebecca are looking at
working on to
fine tune that better during the
updates during the year
for debate does anybody wish to
debate the item
so the recommendations are that subject
to any further budget variations that
arise during the rest of the financial
year the adverse variance of 770
000 pounds referred to in section 6.5 of
the report be noted
and also that the the
2022-23 revised Capital program referred
to in appendix a and section 6.13 be
noted
now ask the governance officer to
conduct the vote
thank you chair the vote is now in
progress
that is eight votes four that's
unanimous chair
thank you very much
moving on now to item 10 this is
MCA slash 22 34.
um
I'm the cabinet member
for this item
so just a quick summary
um this provides a selection of
performance highlights for each of our
six strategic priorities
and it's just intended to give
mid-suffolk members an opportunity to
consider our achievements for Quarter
Two in 2022-23
um before
so I'm just going to select a couple of
items from each of our portfolios
and then if anybody's got any questions
we'll allow the cabinet members to
answer any questions so for economy
um
we had nine new businesses being
supported by the innovate local scheme
in Stone Market
uh in an environment
we've got
just under 18 and a half thousand Garden
waste subscribers
um
signed up
in customers
145 visits to the customer access points
in Stone Market
and a 12 reduction in course
from the previous quarter
for communities
we had a total of 12 new anti-social
Behavior cases
um
and also Community Development grants
was established and open to applications
in Quarter Two
in well-being
39 357 households were supported with
council tax energy rebate
under both the mandatory and the
discretionary screen schemes and this
was almost
5.4 million pounds spent and distributed
to our residents
in housing there was something like 56
cases where homelessness was
successfully prevented or relieved and
this is an increase of 25 cases from the
previous quarter
and in terms of the health of the
organization
uh an average of 1.8
number of Sydney stays per full-time
equivalent
which is a slight increase from quarter
one
with a total of 974 days lost to
sickness which is a decrease from the
previous quarter
I'll now ask for a secondary thank you
councilor Richardson
happy to Second thank you chair thank
you do we have any questions from
cabinet
any questions from other members
councilor field
question really about the the
relevance of this report in December
I was looking under the environment art
up here here and it says parking
strategy oh sorry what we plan to do
next quarter
parking strategy taken to cabinet for
consideration on the 3rd of October
it's now the 5th of December
a few months ago months ago just
wondering whether you feel it's it's
still
appropriate to be reporting
so far in the past
two two months is a fair chunk of a year
you would have thought this this is to
be really useful to us all to see how
we're doing it should be right up to
date
not the sort of thing that obviously
occurs once per quarter you must keep a
running record of many other things uh
reported
I know this is a comment on the question
but the real issue I personally lost the
will to live about halfway through this
report because it's it's there's a shed
load of it if we took out all the stuff
that's ancient history it would be
really much more immediate and of great
interest to ourselves I thought so just
wonder what your thoughts were on that
councilor Fleming
thank you very much
um I have to say I rather agree and I
think it might be a matter of timing and
um which possibly could be adjusted so
maybe
um officers could comment
well I think this is a
a Look Backwards at at what we have done
this is and it does take a while for us
to collate all of these
um statistics and
provide it into
a coherent set of slides and after that
it then comes to our briefing for us to
discuss and agree
and clearly you as portfolio holders
also need to discuss it with your your
equivalent directors so that all takes
time I don't think the time delay
between the end of the quarter and it
coming to us at cabinet I don't think
that's excessive
just wonder whether the assistant
director or the corporate manager would
like to add anything to that
just to clarify is intended as a look
back I appreciate that councilors
might find some further information
helpful in terms of that look forward
and we do try to accommodate that in
terms of what we plan to do next
however I take your your point counselor
field that when we're looking at a paper
that talks about what we're doing next
and that's already in the past that can
be a little confusing and not very
helpful so we will pass some comments
back to corporate managers and their
teams to see if they can make sure that
they take account of that in the
commentary and certainly as we move
forward with our performance reporting
and we look to revamp the whole of this
the work that we do in this space then
we will be looking to see what further
information we can bring to bring it
more up to date and that's helpful but
at the moment it is predominantly a look
back at the previous quarter's
performance
councilor flattman
the officer is actually or the director
has just really said what I was going to
say I was going to say that there are
what we plan to do next topics in here
so everybody knows what's going on for
the next few months but as as she said
definitely it takes time to get all
these figures especially from schools
when you're trying to work out how many
pupils
um joined in with the half events
Etc
so
thank you
thank you so
um
this item is just for noting it only so
oh sorry councilman
sorry I had a question is that okay
um it's a question on on customers which
I think is Page 13.
and we've got some stats there about the
uh abandon rate
the wait time which I assume is for
phone calls
um the wait times have gone up to five
minutes 41 and then we've got 28 of our
calls being abandoned and I hope I've
understood that correctly that does seem
a very high rate
um is that acceptable and what are we
doing to try and bring it down thank you
in the customer access point we do
our officers in that team are very
highly trained
and they have various specializations
which makes them very attractive to
other parts of our organization
so our team in the castle access point
for instance where they specialize in
housing related queries that makes them
very attractive to the housing
directorate and so we do see
significant transfer of some of our
officers from the customer access point
into other areas of the business where
of course their skills are really highly
regarded so we do have quite a high
turnover of officers but also when it
comes to recruitment we
we managed to get people coming in but
there is a really
long time required in order to get the
the new people up to speed and also as a
result of that the existing officers are
spending their time training the new
people and so that does have a knock-on
effect and in the last
um
now whether it's a year or six months
50 of our officers move around the
organization and so that does have a lot
of knock-on effect
and so
um
I believe we're just one person down at
the moment but it uh
so the statistics are getting better and
the abandonment rate has decreased
and the response time is getting better
so I'm happy with the direction of
travel
this report's just for noting
um so thank you all for your questions
moving on now to item 11 and this is the
MCA slash 22 32 the cost of living
crisis
our five-point action plan progress
report and phase two action plan
and I'm going to invite the cabinet
member for communities health and
well-being to introduce this report
councilor flattman
thank you chair
so the cost of living crisis five-point
action plan progress report and the
purpose of the report is to inform
members of our next stage
so options considered
to consider ending our coordinated
approach to the cost of living crisis
and to rely only on coordinating and
promoting any national government
support forthcoming over the next six
months to develop a phase two action
plan which incorporates the learning
from the past six months continuing and
developing the growing Partnerships
across the system
and which supports this work and
improves access to support for our
communities both by internal colleagues
and through external partners
the recommendations are to review and
note the content of phase one cost of
living Five Point action plan and the
dashboard report at appendix one to note
the focus of the phase two Cost of
Living Action Plan and appendix 2.
so if I give you a little bit more D
type detail on those so key information
the cost of living crisis has been
building over the past few months and
continues to impact on our communities
in the district particularly those who
have already been experienced
inequalities pre and post the covid-19
pandemic it is also important to note
that this impact is also being seen in
groups who have previously not been on
our radar people who have never ever
needed help before
so who had been managing despite some
level of difficulty to maintain Reliance
and Independence but who need who are
now needing to come forward for support
the predictions of impact discussed in
the previous cabinet report of the 8th
the 622 have been realized with warnings
of 10 inflation and Associated cost of
living increase now in effect the
drivers for addressing the cost of
living crisis were well articulated in
the cabinet report of June 22. details
of how these issues are developing are
included in the dashboard report
uh covering the past six months at
appendix one there has been a wide range
of national information and thinking to
influence how we go about supporting
people through the crisis both as
residents of our areas and also for our
own staff who are also experienced some
of the same issues and indeed
some of our small businesses which are
also experience these effects local
demands are rising as evidenced by our
colleagues and partners in the voluntary
and Community sector across the board
including the changes seen and the
responded and responded to by Sudbury
and our district and with Suffolk
citizens advice who have been seen X
expectation or increase in demands for
their debt advice Services the attaching
sponge dashboard provides detail of the
impacts and issues arising the work we
have undertaken taken today to address
these issues and some detail on how this
has been progressed and delivered
there has been a great deal of Learning
and Development from the initial plan
and it and it and it's important to know
how quickly different issues have Arisen
and needed a different amended approach
the approach adopted in June 22 to
create a clear action plan to support
both our internal coordination and our
relationships and Joint working with
external Partners has been very
beneficial it has enabled the council to
better understand the impacts across our
services and customers of these changes
and enabled us to focus our resource in
the areas we believe will deliver the
most impact it has also supported
conversations with partners and inform
our priorities
the appointment of the cost of living
coordinator in October has a meat has
has immediately made a significant
difference to our ability to respond to
changes build more conversations with
partners and to support our reporting as
a result of this phase two action plan
has a level of embedded flexibility
which allows the team delivering the
opportunity to react quickly to change
and circumstances such as a new national
government support funding guidance of
specific local issues we have
Incorporated the national and Regional
thinking in our responses over the last
six months and into shaping of the phase
two action plan we have changed the
headings for the phase two action plan
to reflect the national thinking these
are now maximizing income
accessing advice food insecurity and
poverty fuel poverty health and
well-being
the phase two action plan is also shaped
to demonstrate where actions are
responsive to the existing emerging
crisis issues and also looking to the
medium and longer terms to create
opportunities to address the issue of
the Reliance and supporting people
beyond their immediate crisis to build
their capacity Beyond emerging measures
emergency measures once those key issues
have been managed or met this latter
part of the work is informing our
thinking about the wide range of work
seeking to build in resilience for our
residents most at risk
so
the recommendations today are to review
and note the contact of the phase one
cost of living five-point action plan
dashboard report appendix one and to
note the focus of phase two Cost of
Living Action Plan at appendix B which
we have now put in place I don't think I
need a set vendor because the papers
just to note
is that correct yeah you do need to say
because we are voting under
second thank you chair um yes delighted
to Second this report and if I may have
got a couple of points I just want to
make on this paper
um because I know this is an issue that
has been
um a cause of considerable concern
throughout the year
uh recall when I held the health and
wellbeing portfolio and I was asked a
question about this at full Council back
in January
um literally beginning of the year and
obviously things have changed quite
dramatically since then not least the
invasion of Ukraine and the subsequent
impact on energy costs and other
Commodities and but I am really pleased
to see that as a council we have
continually kept the situation under
review and adapted as a result to ensure
that our residents get the support that
they need
um and I strongly welcome the detail in
the appendices both on progress to date
and on the um updated action plan and I
think the point that I really wanted to
make here is entirely agreement with
councilor flatman that we continue to
make the distinction between providing
immediate Crisis Support and on
developing longer-term Community
resilience
because of course we want to help our
residents in what we know will be some
very difficult months ahead but we
shouldn't also lose sight of some of the
longer term objectives that we set out
in the well-being strategy last year a
perfect example of this is food poverty
there is an immediate need to tackle
this over the winter but as a council I
think it is really important that we
sustain our focus on reducing the root
causes of food poverty and the use of
food banks over the longer term and so
I'm delighted to see that this is
reflected in this report to balance
those two two priorities and so I'm very
happy to Second this report thank you
very much chair
um does any Cabinet member have any
questions
councilor Whitehead
yeah I'm reading about in terms of
maximizing income for households where
it says supporting individuals not
economically active to access employment
and
saying people out to work are given
opportunities and advice to help them
access paid employment and thinking
about how mid-suffocus proactively
developed the Gateway 14 site and the
you know the new big company moving in
next year talking about 1600 new
employment vacancies and given the level
of unemployment in the Stow Market I'm
just wondering what we can do to
proactively help those people and to
ensure that you know this local jobs for
local workers as opposed to people being
busted in from you know other parts of
Civic or Beyond as we develop um on that
site what we can do as a communities
team
oh I'm still on um
we have direct links with um the citizen
citizens advice Bureau they are
absolutely
um 100 working their socks off uh that's
why we gave extra 30 30 000 times
to help with this crisis they do a lot
of work with um
with with uh people who are looking for
jobs and they refer them to other
organizations so we have that input
there already but I I really don't I
don't see why not why we cannot lay on
um a careers
um day or off you know to actually show
showcase exactly what jobs will will be
coming along in the very near future and
and you know we could we could do that
that would be absolutely marvelous if
the community's team could get involved
with that with Fiona's team
thank you thank you any other questions
councilor Mellon
yeah thank you I've got two or three
um
the first one is on the
um household support Grant I think it's
sometimes called the household support
fund I hope it's the same pot of money
um obviously we're into the third phase
of that now um
in the first two phases is it correct to
say that these funds have so far
mainly been used to pay off
outstanding Council house rent owing by
a small number of families with the
highest level of arrears and if that is
the case
was that the best way to use these funds
or just the easiest way to use them
that's my first question
I'm sorry I don't have that detail to
hand on the council rents being paid
back I don't know if
um my office my corporate manager might
know
know that though
oh
hi I'll try and answer this question
will you
um
so
um in terms of the household support
fund as you can see in round three we
are trying to prioritize those in the
private rented sector and so those those
proactively as have landlords as well to
promote that with their with their
particular tenants
um
in in the report I think it does say
that there were um around
there was a fair number of
um households supported through the
household support fund and some of those
would have been from from Council and
homes and from our from our particular
stock yeah absolutely but all all cases
would have been considered on a
case-by-case basis
thank you
um
next question just in terms of the theme
of
coordinating government support
um
sometimes seems to me that we're
spending money we're getting from the
government but are we actually spending
any of our own funds on these on these
uh sort of priorities it's a bit
difficult to work out how much of the
money or the funds we're using is is
coming direct from government and we're
just pushing it out or is there anything
of our own money that we're putting into
this as well
definitely
um the 30 000 pounds that came straight
out of our our pocket went to the
citizens advice which dramatically makes
the difference and they were here at
scrutiny and they were very grateful to
what we can do and how we work with them
so closely
um and the government money as well as
well advertised that it does actually
come so that comes into County Council
and then it comes to us to distribute
but all the other activities that we are
funding to keep to work with children
and
um
our grants all our other grants are all
our own money are all our own money but
saying that we do try to maximize and um
meet uh you know get um second funding
because if we put so much money into a
project then we can get match funding so
which we have tried to do and there'll
be an all member briefing coming up as
soon as possible for this whole paper
but not only that to we are going to
show exactly what money we've spent from
the million pound we had for communities
and every time we spend some money
through that million pound we have match
funding come forth so we've almost got
double bubble for what we're doing so
you know that a lot of these projects
will be run with our own money
um yeah one more question then um the
government has announced that uh
households using heating oil for their
main source of heating are to receive a
hundred pounds support
um do we know what the mechanism for for
Distributing this money is and are we
involved in it
sorry I haven't heard yet I don't know
if
uh no I'm not sure how that's being
coordinated
um at the moment in terms of the work
that we have been supporting is through
Community Action Suffolk at the moment
in terms of the coordinating Community
oil buying schemes but
um and also residents can be directed to
the L West which is the local welfare
assistance scheme as well and they will
be provided cash if they need it rather
than any sort of money going direct into
bank accounts um so that's another means
of support in terms of the government
funding I'm not sure how that's
coordinated but I will double check and
respond
cancel the field
thank you just to answer that I think my
oil supplier as of variety said that
you're going to be paid to your
electricity bill
which is interesting if you don't have
an electricity bill but there you go my
question is looking at the um
your report page 75 I think it says
working with Partners to create a single
view database and production of Legally
compliant data sharing agreements in
progress I wonder for how long it's been
in progress because it sort of has a
familiar ring about it things we
a distant past
so in terms of that particular action
item so that is on the look back so that
was the past six months so that was from
the original cost of living five point
plan and it was one of the actions that
we had agreed to look into and the
reason that it is on there as in
progress is because we are now working
with the Suffolk office of data and
analytics and to take on that work so
it's actually something across then the
county also with districts and boroughs
and also vcses to create more of a
shared view of our data across a wider
Network so that is why it is an in
progress piece of work
yeah same thing thanks for that I always
has
distant past as a candy canister one was
told that there's significant gdpr
issues there and exchanging data between
a number of those agencies like Health
Service and the County Council is uh
essentially forbidden at least very
difficult to do so so there's a reason
for the question it sounds like a good
thing to be doing but it could be
extremely difficult to get organized
thank you
and yes so that's why um the Suffolk
office of data analytics are looking at
it because they're working across all of
those different partners and to agree
that process because as you say is quite
complex and it does require data sharing
agreements
um across all of those different
partners so it is currently being looked
at by the the Suffolk County Council
team
a present
thank you
so I'm now going to open up for debate
have a conversation
okay so the recommendations are to
review and note the contents of the
phase one cost of living five-point
action plan dashboard report at appendix
one
and to note the focus of the phase two
Cost of Living Action Plan at appendix
2.
now I'm going to ask the governance
officer to conduct the vote
thank you chair the vote is in progress
that is oh oops excuse me that is eight
votes for that's unanimous chair
thank you very much indeed
so that's the end of the meeting thank
you everybody for your participation the
next meeting is scheduled for Monday the
9th of January
2023 at 10 30.
meeting closed thank you everybody